you
so we'll move on to the second half the
price which was awarded to discovery of
the human immunodeficiency virus this is
a very controversial area it's been a
subject of much high level debate and
public debate could you tell us a bit
about who you given the the prize to and
why you've chosen to give to these
people so there are two researchers who
has got the price Barry sinister and
look Montaigne they collaborated at
institut pasteur in paris with the
discovery and isolation of the first HIV
types HIV type 1 and that is the main
course of acquired immunodeficiency but
we provide the price for the discovery
of the virus because that is the
paradigm shift in these signs they
provided this virus isolate to a number
of other research groups diagnostic
tools were generated by many other
groups and eventually together numbers
of scientists could then definitely link
the HIV through the formation of AIDS so
could you tell us more about the actual
discover itself and why you're choosing
to reward that uses a paradigm shift but
could you elaborate not plain sight they
did several assumption that allowed to
be true first of all they decided to use
lymph nodes a source of the cells that
they captured secondly they decided to
activate the cells in order to try to
get virus production of them thirdly
they consequently and every third day
assess for the potential presence of an
enzyme that is specific for you through
virus reverse transcriptase enzyme and
they were able to demonstrate that
lymphocytes of that type that is
declining in those that are affected by
the disease were the cells that actually
were infected so they not only isolated
the virus they also provided explanation
for why the immune impairment occurred
what their findings actually allow so
that fine is allowed for cloning of the
virus that led the development of
antiretroviral drugs we currently have
two different drugs that have
revolutionized the care of these
invaders infected individuals now get
immune reconstitution and cannot go back
to a normal life and almost have a
normal life expectancy we can also
prohibit mother-to-child transmission of
this virus by these drugs diagnostic
tools that have bevelle own have also
allowed us to restrict the pandemic by
now screening blood products and
infected individuals for potential
infection and so just a sort of recap a
bit is what there was there was a lot of
scientific effort going on the field of
time why why why was this the particular
discover you so it's a paradigm shift
but there was also the linking of the
order of the virus to AIDS so could you
sort of go into a little bit as why you
focused on this discovery rather than
the linking of the virus to that seems
because the discovery of the virus was
really the most important thing without
the discovery of the virus you could
never have done the exact identification
or the course of the disease the cause
of the disease was then the central
paradigm shift the establishment that
this virus actually caused acquired
immunodeficiency were made by many
groups at least seven different
scientific groups in the world
contributed to the definite proof that
HIV causes AIDS and so the the discovery
of the human immunodeficiency virus was
made 25 years ago why has it taken up
till now to award the prize for this
subject is POD that down to the debate
that was going on about who actually
discovered the foot of the virus to some
extent yes because it we don't only lean
on the publications that has been done
we also have other sources that we have
to dissect in order to be sure who
really did the job the French team
actually consisted of 17 different
individuals involved in the discovery
but the two persons that we finally got
the evidence for did the major part on
the discovery was parisa muscle and look
a year and it took us in a number of
years to find out how it really was and
so what rose the T researchers having
discovery so what roles the two
researchers have any actual discovery
they made all the key observation then
set up the technology they made the
protocol they made all the very
important discovery one to each other
the specific enzymatic activity the
toxicity of the helper phenotype the
budding of lambda visitors type of virus
particles from the infected cells and
the immunological properties of this
novel lentivirus that was all
contribution from the two awarded
persons and as I mentioned there has
been a lot of public debate about who
discovered the virus do you expect any
sort of reactions your decision it can
very well be it happens many times and
we can of course only make commands on
the ones that we actually give price you
can actually divide the word in the into
those that have got a Nobel Prize and
those that may get it in the future and
as I mentioned this is this was there's
that price being divided between two to
research areas could you say something
about why the price the medicine
committee decided to split this price
because it actually was two completely
independent price and each of them could
have been given out individually at two
consecutive years but it happened that
the committee were ready and and had
done all the investigation so that were
sure at the same year and then since it
was three persons who had done this it
was possible for the committee to give
shared price sorry divided two divided
price at the same time and is that the
general criterion for dividing a prize
it's whether you have the enough
information of time with the right
number people the most important thing
is each pot has to be able to stand
alone that is it has to be priced worth
each other it's not a combination that
it's priced water
is that each of these discoveries is
price worth thank you very much for that
Professor Radisson thank you a lot more
information about this prize or
interviews or summaries of the prize
please please visit Nobel Prize dork
thank you very much